you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
5-2 game let's try d4 all right and see
form them so Indian let's try f3
okay Samish let's take and see how black
recaptures
with the night okay all right let's take
messy structure I have the bishops they
were threatening my clean let's take
their and probably just take their Jeep
on that's a pretty significant pond so
oh they're not gone after this guy let's
take care and I don't want that night
dropping in there
so let's go here one two three four five
six six I'm up upon and I have the
bishop hair
hmm probably not a good idea what I just
did there on my bishop okay well this is
a little bit awkward I want to play e4
Bishop III King F - I like keeping a
defense of this car
their own castle I have a check here on
h4 forgetting that there's increment
here maybe played the opening too fast
okay got open my bishop size
and maybe I know where my knight belongs
I don't want I would think I want the
Knights exchanged let's get a knight on
d4 why not okay he's definitely heading
here now v2 is weakened hmm I just
strike it B 2 or B 7 ro 2 b1
let's trip let's just start with that
see how they defend I think I still want
to go with this my knight on c3 is
unprotected but I don't think they could
really get at him he's not playing
he's jumping straight in let's go King
f2 night c2 is a bit annoying I think I
should cover that
hmm king of two knights e2 is hitting my
Bishop and pawn
pretty annoying piece is this night yeah
I'm gonna just restrict that night for a
moment I don't want a castle I think my
king will be safe here still a lot of
pieces flying around but I think he
wants to be here maybe even run to g3
one day something like this there's
maybe even pins Mike my king
in short would be opposite that rook if
I'm castling so I thought that that
might be a move let's take okay and I
probably have to take let's do it
now King f2 gotta get this guy working
and my bishop
right here I could
six pawn
like how active the rook is getting
let's go a4
I have checks a couple different checks
let's keep this in mind given time I
want this and then that do I have the
time currently playing without these two
pieces I'm going to be dropping that
pond okay
let's see can I like to undermine this
night with f4 I feel like I'll be
leaving my king vulnerable have 4f6
takes takes you know my king is
accessible don't think I could save my a
pawn probably Bishop d3 yeah let's go
Bishop d3 anything better
I don't think so I got to get my rook
playing
so Bishop takes pawn I don't know how
serious of a pin this is
hello still playing with the bishops
there is no bishop move with check to
win my a rook because I need to be more
specific the a rook minor B's ending
okay two minutes and change
all right I guess we're going to take
they should take with the bishop and now
maybe is the time to undermine yeah
let's do this now maybe even on f6 this
is a move trying to get a passed pawn
over here I also restrict this tonight
this would be a pretty good square for a
knight wouldn't it
this guy's something after watch over if
I do this then Knight here I'm doing
this to grab some space to kill the
knight a little bit I have this secure
if they push I could take the knight and
then take here or can i I'll be dropping
efore so this is an idea they're not
going for it let's get pushing the three
versus two okay well
now I could win some material with
stakes in the night here
they're noticing that now King here to
defend the pond I just want to get their
past pond it was something better than
winning the v6 pond could take this
night first but I'm gonna keep him
around got a window hon
you
maybe there was a reason to take here
because tonight here how am i defending
this guy I guess I have to take this
night now hmm okay
then they have a passed pawn
it's tricky got defend that pond it's
the only way to do it I could have a
little role reversal soon
tonight on c5 tonight on c4 to stop the
pawn Knight on c4 Knight here to defend
and try for something like this watch
out for the forks
only one pawn up
interesting
that's a pretty interesting idea hmm
they're trying to eliminate all my pawns
I could take yeah let's do that
he goes over here I could look to target
that pond
you know let's put pressure on this guy
he might bolt hmm I should do this right
now and take this pawn now to connected
past ponds I'm up to
okay I just want the nights off can I
force the nights off hmm
okay probably here just to stop the king
from getting at this guy okay and now
here yeah I want to flush this King away
from these guys I could care less if he
falls but I want to I want to distract
the King for a moment and now get my
knight back into a good position well
actually I could go one step further I
could give this check
let's give this check and then King F to
play it really simple and try to win
three pawns versus a knight let's just
do this though
that night moves I could take this pawn
this should be pretty clean from here
there's no fancy fork that I see
they hear King up
Yeah right here
threatening d-3 still pawn push here
they found a way to get that there it is
incoming fork yep or that order
okay can I win this it's going to be
extra tough
Wow
oh man those nights as we know are
tricky he found a way to scoop him up
okay my king is at least safe for a
little bit they might be in a little
trouble oh there's that move that works
to get the drop mmm
tough one that's a good game
easy to mess that one up
um just looking at it without the
analysis first this is the one pond I
really need to hang on to
so yeah it's a it's a clever idea I
think that this is working at least to
get this pond it might still be winning
somehow but yeah I shouldn't be dropping
my e4 pond
ya know that cuz the h-bomb typical
trickiness let's see so this wasn't the
right idea I guess night-night check
I was very tempting to do that though
isn't it you know just to kick the king
away yeah I just still should be working
somehow no a night check maybe I go here
yeah I guess I have to go here yeah King
to e1 let's put on the analysis I think
that would be better to go into e1
yeah a double question mark I guess King
f3 is allowing the draw because of push
I got to go here and then Knight here
either move order is good you could
promote first and then land the fork but
switching it up going in there
threatening this that's working as well
hmm okay yep easy to mess that one up
those night endings let's have a look at
the opening okay so a nimzo-indian
camacho variation is what it says here
yeah very sharp playing with the bishops
yeah I don't think that that's
I'm comfortable seeing this because
they're uncounseled I have the bishops
and I'm getting this guy I mean it left
these guys weak not that I was able to
take advantage of these guys but I'm up
upon and I have the bishops and I
probably could have made a better
decision with my bishop at this stage
yeah this is this is a bit too clumsy
I'm running right into development with
tempo so something tells me this is a
better way to stop Knight here knight c6
then e4 and I they probably never even
get their pawn back you know their
activity will my lack of development
eventually meant that you know their
pieces got very active and the Queen
side opened up and I was still with my
bishop on f1 and rook on h1 so yeah I
should see this that it's not a stable
square Bishop h6 knight c6 e 4 and where
does he even go right here seems like
he's ready like he's asking to get
trapped somehow you know he's short on
squares big time so I don't know maybe
here like he did in the game I think
that's where he went when I play d4 yeah
he went to c7 so I help my opponent out
a little bit they gain some time when I
went here bishop there's better
efore and then king f2 Bishop c4 Knight
here and development isn't an issue as
soon as this move is in I could get on
this dog and all right away and look to
circle in it into the d5 square you know
so I wasted some time here probably
playing a little bit too fast but okay
yeah cuz they're there to cover
they're there to cover that oh well you
know what I could play Bishop c4 now now
now I can't
yeah this is this is really off I mean
what am I doing with my bishop it's my
king that wants to be here as well you
know so I'm wasting more time to move my
bishop and get my King on f2 this is
having a complete domino effect on my
position you know by my decision to play
in 2d for this this King f2 right now I
don't need to go here and then this you
know this Bishop is pretty stable peace
if he's being attacked this is a good
way to get your book out of play you
know the action should be somehow over
here but I don't think black would be
there in time okay
so I guess we'll have a look at it with
the engine let's see what the like steam
light or basically the whole game up I'm
up by a great deal and when I see like a
half pond advantage I'm thinking it's
primary primarily related to just having
the bishop pair move 27 f4 yeah I'm not
up on at this point but it's just giving
some some weight of course to having the
bishop hair
so let's just see put on the engine
queens are off is that what it's
suggesting let's just see for the arrows
yeah it does want to go to h6 here still
right around the same evaluation but
yeah I should be going to h6 and now my
pieces are a bit clumsy my bishop is
getting in in the way of my king
yeah I could have organized my pieces
much better in the opening hangout -
okay I think this is the right idea does
it like have five no not a fan of f5
Bishop c1 but you know I just wanted to
take away this square suggesting another
way to get the knight involved and they
helped me out some as well giving me
that pond how could I have better
converted this take the B pond
take the night king f3 yeah this was a
nice try because in these type of
endings you know when you're the
defending side you're down upon what you
really want to have happen is as many
pawns exchanged as possible so that well
as we saw with how it finished here
black eventually got it to a point where
I had one pawn plus well the pawn plus I
had was the only pawn I had and so that
allowed black to it just sacrificed the
night for my remaining punt so blacks
trying to create more pawn exchanges and
that's why you know knowing this this
this is why I'm I'm taking here I know
it's double isolated pawns but it's
still another pawn I have on board if
I'm doing something like meeting h5 with
h3 which is something
maybe be quite common in a middlegame
position you know maintaining your Jeep
on meeting and each pawn advance with an
H pawn advance and thereby maintaining
your Jeep on with a capture recapture
sequence notice you know now it's down
to a 3 vs 2 and we're tending more
towards a situation where the knight can
ultimately sacrifice itself for my my
pawn plus
and get the drop so I'm taking here
they shouldn't be doing that who knows
how really to assess this one it's tough
but h5 takes what could I have done
better here pushing is fine Knight d7
and just get pushing my pawns
I really had you in my mind like I
wanted to win this pawn and then finally
use my king in Knight to escort these
two guys or at least one of them
you know Knight d7 is the move I played
okay
yeah multiple ways to do it but I guess
where it was really lost is when I
played King f3
I have to play King e1 here after King
f3 I guess I'm throwing it away tough
move to see in blitz yeah
tough move to see I gotta go in this
direction though I have to stop this
pawn from advancing
yeah because you know what mmm okay yeah
it's tough to see but at the same time
you know when I play King f3 I'm never
threatening to take the knight but you
know I just I just didn't see this idea
with the follow-up fork and
you know was it still winning at some
point so I should have played kingi one
let's just see this clean approach night
here King here okay now it's now it's
pretty clean I get this guy they get
that one but I should be able to convert
this I'm not gonna I don't think at
least drop both of these pawns it could
still happen you know already there's
this threat to take here but what's this
move about yeah look at how he could
already go round here
if I if I move my king it's already an
issue because of these sacrifices on f5
and there's uh there's checks to to lure
me away so the night could still
sacrifice itself for the pawn still
tricky ending but that's this is what I
wanted is what I'm getting out I wanted
to get this guy first but he wasn't free
I took the D pawn they took the Yvonne
and ya know I guess it's draw town I
didn't miss any wins right around this
point did I hmm
what I was trying to do here is well
could I have played this right now
now they just go back if they take I'm
pushing this check and then getting the
clean but they could just go here and if
I do this there's a night check yeah I'm
not making any progress here
I could try some fancy night moves but
they have it they have it blockaded okay
nights a tricky piece as we all know as
usual feel free to leave any feedback to
this video in the comment section below
and as always I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye